good morning good morning good morning
everybody welcome to gratitude journal
live stream number 23 feels good to be
back happy Wednesday to everybody we do
this every weekday spread some gratitude
recognize the things that we have in our
lives that we are grateful for because
the world needs happier and healthier
entrepreneurs if we're going to solve
all the big problems out there and so we
do this every day at nine a.m. eastern
we share three things that were grateful
for i will share three of mine you guys
share three of yours in the chat are you
watching afterwards share three things
down below make it consistent two key
things that I repeat every time it's
consistent it's a daily habit it's not
just once a week it's something that you
do every single day if you want to feel
the benefits and to that you don't just
list it off but you asked yourself why
why am i grateful for this why is this
important to me and that's when you
start having an emotional connection
that's when you start feeling the impact
you do that consistently for a couple
weeks you'll be a different person I
promise do it with me here every weekday
morning at 9am Eastern or do it on your
own doesn't matter just get it done so
I'm going to share three of mine and
then I'm going to get to the shadows and
read off what you guys are doing a live
chat and what you're capable for the
first one for me I'm really grateful for
a conversation that I had last night I
want to stop by one of my salsa classes
that Toronto then salsa and the
instructor was doing a great job and
then we sat down for almost two hours
afterwards and and talked about it and
talked about how she could get better
talk about she could improve and how she
can go from being just you know a salsa
instructor where people are learning
moves to actually have an a massive
impact on the lives of the people who
are in her class to being their favorite
instructor of anything of all time and
she was really open to it and she we've
had other conversation before but it's
me to see people who want to do great
things and are willing to take feedback
on how to get better just fills me with
so much satisfaction and and it was a
great night I didn't I didn't end up
sleeping much is still kind of leaving
from a high coming back after that but I
grateful for that awesome conversation
and I'm excited to see how her growth
continues in the next few months number
two stick it on the salsa theme I
decided that the business too we're
going to do a salsa routine for the
instructors and the assistants and Nina
and I are going to do it too and we
haven't I haven't done anything for a
long time terms of learning a routine
and I'm I should I'm pretty excited
almost everybody is joining us in the
group who are part of our instructors
and assistance and I'm just I'm grateful
for having the opportunity to be able to
learn something new and create the
situation for myself where if I want to
learn something new I can just go and
create it and not have to rely on other
people to do it for me and I get to
create the opportunity for others you
know for the other people on my team the
here's something that they can do that
you know I'm paying for that can help
further their growth and development so
I'm super excited and grateful for that
new opportunity to tell that that was
created and number three it's it's
Wednesday its video day I love video day
i'm probably gonna have a special guest
with me today filming for the end
specials for the week and you know with
every passing wednesday i recognize
increasing the importance of of today of
the work that i have to go and do today
of the 20-something videos that i need
to go on record today and how you guys
are going to watch and believe nation is
going to be paying attention and how
much you guys kind of can rely on the
content that I'm creating in your daily
lives you know I feel the weight
increasingly every week and I feel the
pressure
to to do better to give you something
better I just spent the last two days
working on one top 10 video Tyrese
Gibson I've never spent it was insane
I'm behind on my videos because this
Tyrese Gibson two full days almost
working on this top 10 video of my time
on top of what my team already put in so
I'm grateful to have the opportunity
today to go in and make videos and I'm
going to try to channel your strength
and energy into that to give you
something amazing for the next week and
that's that's always intent going in in
the super people for this platform so
those are my three things people for the
conversation last night we prefer the
salsa routine coming up and grateful
that is Wednesday and video day let's
get to the live chat what are you guys
grateful for let's see it leave it there
three things you're grateful for and i'm
going to give some shoutouts first up j
reyez thankful for my bed pillows and
covers I'm important for physical
pleasure and sexuality for creating for
creative inspired divinely elegant
solutions I love that movie villa
grateful for spirituality and knowledge
I love that J reyez is also grateful for
cutting-edge GoPro technology that
allows us to document high-value moments
when 19 and I went away on our last trip
it's been a while um I filmed almost all
the videos on the GoPro it was actually
pretty good except you need
stabilization you can't just hold it
chicks too much but otherwise it was
really cool especially the time lapses
Rishi kept TV grateful for my free
hashtag cup of coffee courtesy of my
cups app today I'm feeling we're gonna
be talking about that later that in the
league of legends live stream the
ability to ask questions when we want to
learn more and teachers who change lives
every day a couple of everyone it's true
it's true and and you know the teachers
in the traditional sense of school
teachers but also this business teachers
life teachers salsa teachers
I'm really you know you should all be a
teacher of something whatever your
message is you should be out there
teaching others teaching the next
generation teaching the people who don't
have the skills and knowledge to get to
where they want to be so embrace your
inner teacher que el bien good morning
everyone welcome back relaxing sleep
station I'm grateful for my girlfriend's
visa application process moving to the
next stage grateful for the nice cool
weather today and grateful for the
insights of Tim Ferriss I'm a Tim
Ferriss fan too i'm wondering what you'd
recently learned that was exciting but i
love it Kilby and I'm grateful for skype
for allowing me to study with a partner
living 500 miles away I love that
without sherry good morning all you
beautiful people good morning cheri what
do we got what do we got what do we got
Kilby and I'm game prefer for focus t25
lower focus exercise because now my legs
feel like spaghetti I don't know what
that exercise is but it's awesome that
you're you're getting the workout in
arrest a 2103 good morning everyone hey
hey arrested what's up man sorry and
good morning Evan Zeno during
yesterday's business Q&A live stream
Rishi mentioned why wasn't there I had
to go to the hospital with a family
member it was a little scary but things
seem ok now feeling the love say no hope
everything's okay uh Jay mean hello
friends good morning Anthony Lopez good
morning people of success I love that
Anthony nice Zeno I wanted to say I'm
very grateful for your positive thoughts
and prayers thanks guys the leaf nation
showing up Kelly good morning give them
four good tires oil changes and
bluetooth for my car makes a long drive
much better happy driving may be
listening to some live streams in the
car novel hazing I hope all is good now
I love it uh Stacy I love salsa where do
you go I own the largest salsa day in
school probably North America so that's
where I go trauma dead salsa when we got
what do we got what do we got what do we
got
Xena I mentioned before but after what
happened yesterday I'm extra gaming for
doctors and nurses their jobs are so so
important I love it Jackie good morning
grateful to be back missed a couple days
it's beautiful that we're where we are
grateful to have you back Jackie welcome
back people for generous people and my
unexpected gifts today grateful for
morning hugs you know something that
Nina's insisting on that there's a
morning hug before she leaves so it's
something that we've tried to continue
as a tradition if I don't do the more we
hug than I i get i get yelled at so
morning hugs are important cool guys
nine ten thank you for the fun we're
both the hop on the twitch and do a live
stream playing league legends business
QA answering your entrepreneurial
questions you can join us there if not
then enjoy the rest of your day show
some gratitude go and crush whatever
you're about to do today continue to
believe or whatever your one where it is
and i'll see you soon